starting off this hour is going to be
randy in baltimore maryland hey randy
welcome to the dave ramsey show
how are you doing mr randy hope all is
well for you and thank you for taking my
call
my pleasure sir how can i help so
currently i'm 23 years old
uh and i earned about 60k a year
uh and i feel like right now maybe
making poor financial decisions
um my question is what advice would you
give someone
my age that wants to learn more about
you know making smarter financial
decisions
and you know understanding things such
as you know exactly what is the mutual
fund
what is a roth ira what's a traditional
ira and how can we make these things
work to our advantage
wow um and also what is what do you
think we should do you know we can do
right now
at our age so that we can build wealth
so you know 20 30 years down the road
you know we can live a comfortable life
yeah good for you
very cool what do you do for a living
sir oh so i'm a
child analysis working for a contracting
company okay
very good well really really good
questions randy
and uh very wise to ask those kinds of
questions
so what happened to me was uh when i was
your age i started buying and selling
real estate and i got rich
i ended up with about four million
dollars worth but a whole bunch of debt
and the short version of the story was
the bank called our notes
and we ended up losing everything going
completely broke
and um by the time i was 28 i was
bankrupt so i was a millionaire by the
time i was 26 by the time i was 28 i was
bankrupt
at the bottom of that mess is the only
time i got enough wisdom to ask the same
questions you're asking
i started saying okay how does money
work because apparently i don't freaking
know
i made a lot of it but i couldn't keep
it so i had something wrong with my
formula
how does money work and so i went on a
quest to try
to figure out how money works now uh
you're doing a very wise thing and
that's what i did i started interviewing
people who seemed to know now
what i did was i said i don't want to
talk to people who have theories i want
to talk to people who have money
if you want to be skinny talk to skinny
people
if you want to be married a long
fruitful marriage
don't talk to people been divorced 16
times and wrote a book about it
talked to people that have been married
67 years and didn't kill each other
which is by the way quite an
accomplishment so uh
talk to people who are successful in a
field
of endeavor that you want to be good at
and ask them
what are they doing so i talked to old
rich people not young rich people i had
been him i didn't want his opinion he
was obviously stupid he went broke
i had a lot of opinions when i was 26
and i was a millionaire but they were
obviously wrong
so i didn't want get rich quick dude's
opinion i wanted people who
had no hair or gray hair and had money
i don't want your broke brother-in-law's
opinion and i don't want a professor
who's tenured and is broke to give me an
opinion about personal finance class
no thank you it's not it's not
appropriate i want to talk to old rich
people
and as a christian i also started
studying what the bible says about money
which is weird i know
but it's there and there's a lot of
stuff in scripture about money but it's
all kind of common sense it's not
not much of it's mystical or spiritual
most of it's just like
the borrower is slave to the lender if
you ever had a big buck car payment you
know that's true
you know you don't have to really think
about that one duh they are if
you ever had a car repo'ed you know the
borrower slave to the lender right
if you've had sallie mae in a spare
bedroom for 28 years you know the
borrower's slave to the lender
you are slave to that woman and so and
she's ugly too
so i mean you start to know those things
so i started comparing those biblical
ideas
with what the old rich people said and
they aligned perfectly and really they
became they really are what's called
common sense
but it turns out common sense is so rare
in our culture
that it's like having a superpower and
so
what i started doing was following these
basic
really primitive principles
to the nth degree i don't borrow money
when you don't have any payments and you
earn a living
you know what you have money
so i quit borrowing money
i don't have any payments what's the
best interest rate on your credit card
i've got a the best interest rate on all
credit cards i don't have one i don't
own a credit card
i haven't for 40 years oh and i'm worth
hundreds of millions of dollars
go figure you know good lord the
building we're sitting in is worth 100
million
you know unbelievable you guys so
seriously this stuff works i've been
doing it for 40
years so how do you learn about things
randy the way you're asking is very very
smart
is you learn about them from someone
who's done it before the stuff we teach
on how to do a mutual fund what a mutual
fund is how to invest how to get out of
debt
how to be on a budget if you'll follow
that plan exactly
it is without a doubt the most proven
plan
in the world we've led more people out
of debt and more people into wealth than
any other organization on the planet
right now by far
nobody's even close and there's other
people that talk about stuff but we've
we've had millions tens of millions of
people
not only get out of debt but we've made
millions of millionaires
and showing people how to do this stuff
so i'll show you how to do it
it comes into a thing called ramsey plus
and you go through financial peace
university
and you get on a budget with the every
dollar app
and you start following your progress
with the baby step tracker app
and we will show you exactly step by
step now here's the mistake everybody
makes randy
they start where you started and where i
started
when i crashed from the wonderful
wise place of humility you're saying
i don't know how to do this i'm making
bad decisions
i want to make better decisions that's
the beginning of wisdom
but as soon as things start going right
most people become geniuses
and they decide they have to fix a plan
that has helped millions of people and
instead they're going to do their
version
and so they start doing ramsey-ish
instead of just doing what the freak
they're supposed to be doing
why is this hard why but it's human
nature we get cocky as soon as we do as
soon as we're not humble anymore
and so you're starting from a really
good place if you'll just stay there and
do
exactly what i show you to do you're
gonna be wealthy
it works a hundred percent of the time
if you work
and earn a living and live on less than
you make and stay out of debt
and build an emergency fund and invest
fifteen percent of your income
and get your mortgage paid off in 15
years and you keep putting money in your
401k and getting your match and doing
your roth ira
100 of the time you're gonna become
wealthy
if you don't do all the other stupid
stuff and they're stupid around every
corner trying to trip you
but you just gotta know where stupid is
and go nope nope not playing with that
not playing with that not doing that i
don't know nope nope that's going to get
me there
so hang on i'm going to sign you up
brother for ramsey plus
i'm going to pay for it it's one
membership that coaches you step by step
through
all of our best products and you're
going to be an expert on money
and i'm going to walk with you for the
next decade in ramsey plus showing you
how to do it
and i'm going to give you the first year
free there's access to financial coaches
there's the premium version of every
dollar there's financial peace
university which is the
premium class ever taught on money i
mean you really cannot beat this stuff
and i'm giving it to you free because
you were humble
enough to ask for help i'm proud of you
sir